so what makes anxiety healthy anxiety is
healthy when it is serving as an alarm
system that lets us know that
something's not right that it gets our
attention and helps us to keep ourselves
safe the only time we consider anxiety
to cross the line from healthy to
unhealthy is under two conditions
actually one is when we have anxiety but
there's no threat that there's nothing
wrong so if it's you know a lovely
Sunday morning and you're taking a drive
and there's no traffic nearby you
shouldn't be having an anxiety response
in that moment and if you do we would
consider that grounds for concern the
other time we pay attention to anxiety
and consider it to be unhealthy is if
the anxiety response is way too big for
what's happened out of proportion to
events so if somebody swerves and cuts
you off and you have a panic attack in
that moment that is not healthy anxiety
it is not helping you and we would
address that clinically other than that
we really see anxiety as largely normal
protective healthy
and useful in our lives